Be sure to subscribe to Lang Focus and
click the notification button.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be talking about languages
without verb tenses,
languages without verb tenses,
how's that possible speakers of English
and other Indo European languages and I
guess other languages too might take it
for granted that the basic features of
their language must be present in other
languages as well,
but that's not always the case.
One example of this is verb tense using
a particular form of a verb to show the
time period of an action past,
present,
or future as they exist on a timeline
and English.
We basically have these three tenses.
Present tense is represented by the
simple verb stem like play for example
with regular verbs.
The past tense is represented by the
stem plus the inflection ed like played
and the simple future tense is formed by
placing the modal auxiliary verb will
before the infinitive,
which is based on the verb stem minus
two for example,
we'll play.
Some linguists might argue that this
future form is not actually a verb
tense.
We'll come back to that later,
but some languages don't have verb
tenses,
meaning they don't have different verb
conjugations to show periods of time.
This is true of many creole languages,
for example,
of Indonesian and Malaysian of Chinese
have many native American languages and
a lot more.
Here's an example from Indonesian.
Here's the verb,
meaning pay in the past,
present and future.
Mumbai Outta the form of the verb is
exactly the same and all three tenses,
and this might sound strange to you,
how can they clearly communicate without
being able to say when an action takes
place?
Well,
first of all,
it's normally not that hard to guess
from context.
Just to illustrate,
let's take the English word put,
which is the same in the present tense
and past tense.
I put my keys on the table so it was
that sentence,
present tense or past tense in the
middle of a story taking place.
In the past it would probably be past
tense,
but if someone were describing that
action as part of their daily after work
routine than it would probably be
present tense.
Context can clarify the time of an
action.
Aside from general context.
There are other ways of indicating when
an action takes place first through our
words and expressions that indicate a
specific time that the action takes
place like today,
yesterday,
next week,
last year,
et cetera.
Second,
there are adverbs that indicate aspect.
For example,
so the mum Biota,
which basically means already paid sit
dung,
Mumbai Iota,
which means in the process of paying
Massey Mumbia,
which means still paying these adverbs
show aspect.
What's the difference between tensen
aspect?
As I mentioned before,
temps indicates the time period of an
action past,
present,
or future aspect deals with the way
actions unfold in relation to the
timeline rather than where they occur.
On the timeline.
Suda shows that an action is completed
with the focus on the result of the
action.
We could call this perfect aspect,
sit down marks the imperfection of
aspect showing that an is in progress,
but the action is not necessarily in the
present tense.
Massey also marks the imperfect of
aspect,
showing that an action is continuing,
but with an emphasis on the fact that
it's not yet finished.
These are just three of the many aspect
markers in Indonesian.
Another language without tenses is
Mandarin.
Chinese.
I mentioned this in my video comparing
Chinese and Japanese,
but unfortunately I messed up my
explanation a little bit.
Here's the present tense sentence I gave
him.
That video will achieve.
She sell.
This means I go to school.
The verb she is the same.
No matter what period of time it takes
place in,
but there are words that can be placed
before or after the verb which show
aspect.
Well,
it should I share.
This means I went to school,
indicates the perfective aspect,
viewing an action in its entirety
including its completion at a point in
time.
This is often thought of as a past tense
marker,
but in certain contexts it can be used
with future events.
For example,
this means I'll call you after I've had
a meal tomorrow.
Time can also be indicated with
time-related vocabulary,
so let him what?
Chyna.
This means yesterday I went to school.
You can see that we've added the word
for yesterday.
In this sentence,
we actually still need the perfective
aspect marker because the verb here is
an action verb with a definite start and
finish,
but in some sentences the perfective
aspect marker is not needed,
for example,
so let's will coc.
This means yesterday I arrested here.
There's no aspect marker and the only
indication of time is the word meaning
yesterday.
Here's a sentence with a different
aspect marker.
Well,
sad.
She she,
I saw the Lou Shannon.
This means I'm on the way to school.
This word that shows in perfective
aspect indicating an action that is in
progress and again,
not necessarily in the present and this
part at the end here means on the road.
These are two common aspect markers and
mandarin,
but there are others.
The main thing to notice with the
Indonesian and Mandarin examples is that
the verb itself has not conjugated.
You simply place a different word and
aspect marker next to the verb.
It's actually very common for languages
to not have tents,
but I've never heard of a language that
doesn't have aspect in many languages.
Tencent aspect combined together to form
various verb conjugations and many
people really don't distinguish between
the two concepts.
For example,
in English we have the present tense as
in I work and we have another form I'm
working which is in the present tense
but with progressive aspect and we have,
I have worked which is in the present
tense but with perfect aspect showing a
connection between a past event and the
present.
People tend to think of all of these
different verb constructions as tenses,
but strictly speaking there is more than
just tense there.
There are certain languages that do have
tenses but not all of them in
particular.
It's quite common for languages to show
no distinction between present tense and
future tense.
This is the case with Japanese for
example,
which has two tenses.
Past and non past could mean I eat
Japanese food in the general sense or
I'll eat Japanese food in a specific
case.
In the future.
It's normally not hard to tell the
difference based on context and there's
another form Tay you do,
or t Mohs,
which represents a continuing action or
continuing state incorporating uses of
both progressive as well as perfect
aspect.
People often think this is strictly a
present tense form,
but it can also be used for future
actions.
For example,
the sentence means I can't believe that
around this time next week I'll already
be living in Canada.
Here you can see that the verb say
[inaudible] is in the Teo to form
representing progressive aspect,
but the action takes place in the
future.
Many linguists would even argue that
English has no future tense.
That's because there are no inflections
on the main verb to show future tense,
but it's shown instead using a modal
auxiliary specifically will modal
Auxiliaries and general indicate
likelihood ability,
permission and obligation.
We'll does express future action,
but syntactically it works like a modal
auxiliary and there's also the
construction going to which can be
placed in front of the main verb,
indicate the future.
Semantically speaking,
English can express the meaning of the
future tense using these constructions,
but grammatically they're not really a
future tense.
But again,
most people tend to think of that as the
future tense in English.
Indeed,
many of the verb forms that we tend to
think of as tenses include elements
other than tents.
Take French for instance,
which is usually thought to have 14
tenses,
seven simple tenses and seven compound
tenses.
But the seven compound tenses contain an
element of aspect.
Show them through the use of auxiliary
verbs and the conditional and
subjunctive forms show distinctions in
mood.
The conditional form suggests that one
action is dependent upon another and the
subjunctive form indicates desire or
probability.
These are moods and even though they
have separate verb forms and are often
referred to as separate tenses,
they really express both tents and mood.
So verb tenses may work differently in
different languages,
and some languages may lack grammatical
verb tense entirely,
but that doesn't mean that they can't
express those different time periods in
other ways,
whether from context,
from the use of time expressions like
tomorrow from the use of aspect or from
the use of modal auxiliaries,
when some people hear that there are
languages with no verb tense,
they imagined that the speakers of these
languages have no understanding of time,
that they can't plan for the future or
that they can't remember the past or
something like that.
But that's not the case at all.
We're all humans after all,
and we all find ways to communicate the
same basic things.
The question of the day,
does your language have special verb
forms to express past,
present,
and future?
Does your language contain a large
number of tenses that incorporate aspect
and mood?
If you're not quite sure,
maybe look it up and find out a little
bit about it and tell us in the comments
down below,
be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters,
especially these wonderful people right
here on the screen for their monthly
pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Okay.